foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI I meet the mayor of
London to Decon to find out more about
his new free School meals plan
Blast Off meet the two Scouts who got to
see a SpaceX rocket launch in their
report for FYI
[Music]
hello this is a FYI the Weekly News show
where we bring you all the latest info
on all the big stories coming up we'll
be marking World Book Day by chatting to
author and illustrator of The Tom Gates
books Liz pishon but first one of the
big issues we know you really care about
yeah free School meals are a Lifeline
for millions of families across the UK
struggling with the rise and cost of
food just over 2 million pupils get a
free lunch to help parents who are
struggling but unfortunately not
everyone qualifies for free School meals
which means thousands of children who
really need them are still missing out
recently we spoke to the education
secretary Jillian Keegan and asked if
the government was going to do more to
make sure that no one goes hungry what
you're trying to do is make sure it gets
to the most disadvantaged people and
then the other thing that we put in was
free School meals for all infants
and now we've just put in breakfasts in
those areas that are more deprived well
recently the mayor of London city con
announced that from September all
primary school children will be given a
free School Meal pretty cool right well
I got to meet Mr Khan to find out more
money to have a decent meal three times
a day has been getting harder for many
families for a while it's all down to
the rising cost for food
to Decon the mayor of London has
announced free School meals for all
primary school children across the
capital
so why have you decided to give free
School meals to primary school children
in London I think it's really important
every child has at least one nutritious
hot healthy meal a day unfortunately in
our great city of London every day
there's about 210
000 children who are in poverty but
they're not receiving a free School Meal
which is a reception up until year six
in London we'll receive a free school
meal I know a lot of people might be
confused why they've decided to start it
in September I mean they live in crisis
is a from people now we've got a
situation where School kitchens aren't
quite eroded to ramp up the amount of
free School meals that we would need so
if we said I wanted to do it from
Tomorrow it'd be chaos so we're going to
give the schools and the councils time
for the start of the next academic year
which is September but it's also the
time of year when we know people's
heating bills will go up families who
aren't yet in receipt of free School
meals really struggled making ends meet
what about during the holidays I mean
the living crisis doesn't stop affecting
people during the holidays I am worried
about holidays so we're working with
some great Charities we're making some
announcements when it comes to the
holidays later on this year why you guys
think free School meals are important
the cost of living crisis as some
families can't afford it and having a
warm meal would be very beneficial if
this free parents could relax more
everyone should have the right to have a
full meal because if your parent didn't
have the time to make a big nice bowl of
pasta and someone else's did it would be
really unfair because someone would be
going home hungry while the other
person's filmed it would be like amazing
to have free foods it will just change
so many people's lives financially is
also lunch keeps you going in the middle
of the day it's it's one of the main
meals of the day I found that getting
free School meals can be pretty
complicated it depends on how much your
parents earn how much financial support
you get from the government and it also
depends on where you live
in Scotland all primary schools give
most their pupils free lunches and Wells
is about to follow but not in Northern
Ireland or England and for those of you
in secondary school your parents have to
be on benefits and earning a very low
wage of 7 400 pounds a year to qualify
for a free School Meal
Children's Charities say this is unfair
and claim there are eight hundred
thousand children in need of free School
meals you just don't get them have you
thought about Secondary School pupils I
mean do you think there's enough access
for kids above the age of 11. no at the
moment in secondary schools it's the
case there are children between 11 and
18. who are going hungry going hungry
why because they're not eligible for
free School meals what I want the
government to do is to provide free
School meals for all children in primary
schools and secondary schools and what I
want the government to do is say look if
the mayor can do it in London we should
be able to do it as well
[Music]
it kind of sea slug spotted on the West
Coast of Australia called the Spanish
dancer it's bright orange and red colors
are meant to scare away potential
Predators but is it a real sea slug or
just fake news we've been investigating
find out later
[Music]
it was one birthday recently a day to
celebrate books reading and of course
dressing up as your favorite fictional
characters so we went to penworthan
Primary School in South London to hear
from pupils and FY news club there about
why they love reading
[Music]
I love reading because it can take me to
a different place and I can just really
experience what the characters are
feeling what about you you can just dive
into your book and Escape reality and
also I love how it's about things like
in real life like adventure books like
they can like increase your knowledge
and ideas and like every book has a
meaning for example this book has 25
happy poems to like cheer you up I like
strong girl characters because in books
like main characters or girls that are
like really strong and brave I like that
there's always a Twist at the end and
some books have humor what about you it
depends on what type of book it is
because if it's a non-fiction book I
like learning the facts well I think
it's good to read books it's because
you're well-being and it takes you to a
different world it creates a picture in
my head about what's happened even if
the book doesn't have any pictures it's
better to not have pictures so you can
imagine it in your own world I like
reading because it stretches your
vocabulary it just calms me down and
it's just fun
[Music]
football fans through thousands of
cuddly toys and teddy bears onto the
pitch during a match in Istanbul for
children affected by turkey and Syrian
earthquakes the players clapped and more
emotional as they rush to collect the
Sea of soft toys which will be shipped
to those in need
well another book character you might
know is the doodle loving Tom Gates and
we're joined Now by his creator
illustrator and author Liz pishon well
Liz thank you so much for joining us so
who is Tom Gates and what are the books
all about so I wrote Tom um 11 years ago
as the first book came out and he's
really based on me of what I was like as
a kid I write about all the small
details of his life like his school life
friends pets and he's very keen on
drawing and doodling as well school is
great
I write about lots of things that
happened in my own life and I think some
of those things children all over the
world you know can relate to them like
you know having a grumpy teenage sister
and that kind of thing she's the best at
being grumpy
so how did you come up with the idea so
I used to illustrate other people's
books and nobody was giving me funny
books to illustrate and I used to do
lots of drawings and I started drawing
this character and it just looked like a
Tom I guess it is really important if
you have an idea is really important to
just go for it like you're absolutely
right yeah I mean I'd never written a
book for older children before I used to
write picture books and now I'm writing
book 21. and also I was dyslexic as well
so I never thought in a million years I
would ever end up writing books for
children so just keep at it you've got
to find the right thing to do that's
amazing because it shows everyone that
even if you have dyslexia it doesn't
matter you can still do whatever you
want write books well these
illustrations look amazing yeah they
really do are they really hard to do
they're not honestly it's the simplest
illustration style I'm going to show you
how to draw a monster which is a
character from the book one of the
things I always say don't worry about
making a mistake this style of drawing
anybody can do I'm going to start in the
middle of the page yeah so just draw a
straight line down and we're going to
draw a book this is the book spine so
you need to do like a little rectangle
and then do exactly the same thing on
the other side and I'm just drawing a
few extra lines there so it makes it
look like there's a little so it's
drawing a book then we're going to draw
the monster we're going to draw a line
down
then it's almost like you're drawing an
m at the top there and then one across
and do the same one at the top there so
let's do his feet
I say feet they're kind of just made up
two little hands there so he's holding
the book draw one big eye
and then one small eye and what I call a
letterbox mouth which is just like a
letterbox I'm going to draw some teeth
you want to do the dots of the eyes down
like that so it looks like it's reading
the book
okay yeah I think I'm finished okay
ready one two three here are Monster
Doodles well I think I might have to
keep practicing that but thank you so
much for joining us oh it's been an
absolute pleasure no it's been really
fun thank you very much thank you
coming up a report from two Scouts who
are mad about space
[Music]
so did you think this strange sea slug
was fake or fact well it's actually
facts this sea slug was spotted on the
West Coast of Australia and is known as
the Spanish dancer because it looks like
a flamenco dancer's Skirt In Motion it's
also been nicknamed the pizza of the sea
although I wouldn't recommend eating it
check out our webpage for more details
on how to spot if something is fake or
fact
here
hi I'm Craig hi I'm Simon we're scouts
and we're here in Cape Canaveral Florida
and we're going to watch Rocket Blasters
off awesome
when we heard that astronaut Tim Peake
will be running a competition with the
scouts and seeing a rocket blast off is
the prize we got straight to work we had
to come over ideas for a satellite could
be used for in the future set about some
machines they're all based on Earth and
could be used to transmit phone or TV
signals take photos of space or Earth
and monitor where the patterns or carry
out experiments but to get them there
you need one of these this isn't just
any rocket it's a SpaceX rocket it's the
kind that Elon Musk and his team
invented the world's first reusable
rocket that blasts off into space and
returns to Earth to be used again
the rocket will be taking it in master
satellite then the is6 F2 into space as
a lifespan of over 15 years so there are
a lot of different ways it can be used
throughout its time and space
my invention was to have a range of
satellites in orbit and they would
communicate together to quickly store
and process data from around the world
at the moment data fields on Earth
produce a lot of heat and that heat then
pollutes the environment my idea was
come up with a cheap and eco-friendly
source of energy by collecting the
energy from the Sun using solar panels
on the satellite and then beating that
down to earth and that can be cheap
anything friendly I'm most excited for
the launch this evening I think it's
going to be incredible I'm also really
looking forward to the launch this
evening I think it's going to be really
really nice and loud
never seen before five four three two
one engines full power and liftoff of
Falcon 9 and then Mark that go falcon go
in Marshall
that was incredible an amazing launch
maybe one day myself will go up into
space that'd be incredible
if you have a story and want to report
on FYI get in touch via our webpage or
even better get your teacher to set up
an FYI News Club at your school members
get the chance to report for us we'll
even help you film Your Own Story you
can watch and discuss the latest
episodes with free resources every week
[Music]
a group of young climate activists from
Austria are taking their government to
court because they believe they're not
doing enough to tackle climate change
they'll argue in court that Austria's
climate law doesn't do enough to protect
them from potentially life-threatening
consequences of global warming the
Austrian legal action is based on a
similar case that happened in Germany
where nine young climate activists
successfully forced Germany's climate
laws to be changed with clear targets to
reduce emissions of gases that lead to
global warming by 2030. there have been
other successful cases in the
Netherlands and Colombia and across the
world young people are trying to get
their governments to listen and to take
action remember him though the walrus
has finally finished his UK tour and has
landed in Iceland he's massive isn't he
Thor Drew crowds a few months ago when
he was first spotted in Hampshire before
spending New Year in Scarborough and
then traveling a further 70 miles north
to Blythe in Northumberland
he has now been seen a further 850 miles
north on the east coast of Iceland he
has previously visited the Netherlands
in France and you thoughts he have
originally traveled all the way from the
Canadian Arctic
well Thor isn't the only Arctic Wonder
that's been spotted in the UK in a very
rare display the Northern Lights have
been seen as far south as Kent and
Cornwall recently
so according to my research they are
caused by the sun which sends out a
stream of electrically charged particles
called solar flares they are attracted
to the North and South Poles by magnetic
fields found there they mix with gases
in the atmosphere causing the gases to
Glow we can often see them in Scotland
but they're rarely seen in Southern
England
we'll leave you with very rare footage
of the incredible Northern Lights in the
skies across the UK bye
[Music]